Six months into America's COVID-19 pandemic cases are surging, small businesses are faltering,
playgrounds are empty, and unemployment is at 11%.
Our best hope for ending this nightmare is a vaccine and there are more than 165 in development.
But when a vaccine becomes available how many Americans will refuse it?
Bill Gates vaccine is magically ready,
but in order to get the vaccine you also have to receive the biometric tattoo.
Will you take it?
I don't trust the vaccines, I never did.
And be able to force things into your body that then slowly debilitate you with binary weapon systems
and kill you.
Vaccines are the greatest healthcare advance of our time preventing an estimated 4.5 billion infections
since their advent.
So what explains the reluctance of so many Americans to vaccinate?
It's a combination of bad science the government's long history of misleading the public and the collapse
of confidence in public health authorities because of their catastrophic failures in response
to the COVID-19 pandemic.
But if the government responds by attempting to force Americans to take a COVID-19 vaccine
it will only help the conspiracy theorists.
Public health officials can begin to undo the damage of the past six months by rejecting authoritarian
and paternalistic approaches in favor of careful persuasion and brutal honesty
about the limits of their own knowledge.
Though most Americans surveyed say they'll probably take the vaccine there's a real possibility
that a sizable block of refusers could allow this Novel Coronavirus to continue spreading
based on what's happened with measles,
and vaccine refusal tends to happen
in clusters according to researcher Tara C. Smith.
2019 was the worst measles year in a
generation when you have some of these
groups of individuals where vaccination
rates are low
it just takes one person with measles to
get in there and spread it through a
community
vaccine skeptics often focus on the
claim that
childhood vaccines cause autism i think
they
need to wake up and stop hurting our
kids the vaccines
are dangerous if not given a dangerous
to certain people who are more
susceptible
two years old two and a half years old a
child a beautiful child
went to have the vaccine and came back
and
a week later got a tremendous fever got
very very sick
now is autistic the claim famously was
amplified by a british researcher named
andrew wakefield i started getting calls
from parents who said
my child was developing perfectly
normally and then they had their mmr
vaccine
in many cases and then they just
disappeared his 1998 paper linking
vaccines and autism
was later retracted and the uk general
medical council found him guilty of
multiple ethics violations for lying
about his test subjects
and failing to disclose a financial link
to an anti-vaccine lawsuit
but concern about vaccines is rising
among parents
along with objections to the use of
mercury preservatives
which both haven't been proven to do
harm and haven't been present in
childhood vaccines for nearly 20 years
an ecosystem of anti-vaccine information
has emerged and according to the
american journal of public health
bots and paid russian trolls participate
in online vaccine debates
far more than the average social media
user and the trolls don't always join
the anti-vaccine side of the debate
but aim to elevate the visibility to
create false equivalency
eroding public consensus on vaccination
you have some people that
really don't know what to think so you
know we think of them as kind of fence
sitters
and they're really just trying to figure
out you know what is going on what do i
believe what do i trust
largely those people in the middle are
the ones that that i try to reach
but u.s public health authorities have
sometimes misled the public about
vaccines and other public health
interventions
which has made the job of convincing
skeptics more difficult
the united states government did
something that was wrong
deeply profoundly morally
wrong the tuskegee experiment so
deep distrust of the government and
public health particularly in black
american communities
in 1932 government doctors recruited
mostly poor black sharecroppers at the
tuskegee institute
for a study of the impact of syphilis
the participants
the majority of whom had the disease
were told they were getting an
experimental medicine when in fact they
were all given a placebo
scientists running the study were
actually interested in the progression
of the illness when left
untreated the experiment continued until
well
after penicillin became available in
and many participants died they were
lied to
by their government another incident
that damaged trust in public health
occurred in 1976
when a novel virus called the swine flu
broke out at a u.s army base
and scientists believe that it bore a
genetic similarity to the 1918 flu
that had killed more than 100 million
people worldwide
offer every american the opportunity to
be inoculated
against a swine type influenza virus
president gerald ford authorized 135
million dollars to develop
and deploy a vaccine and the government
injected 25 percent of americans in a
10-month period
but the global pandemic never came the
disease died out
and the rushed version of the vaccine
likely resulted in some
injuries though probably not as many as
reported by the media at the time
smith says more humility is called for
in public health communication it's hard
but i think we have to emphasize that
uncertainty
and i think that may have been one thing
missing with the masks and i was
probably guilty of it myself you do not
have to wear
masks because there is no evidence
that they protect people who are not
sick over the weekend
the u.s surgeon general urged people to
stop buying masks saying
in a tweet they are not effective in
preventing general public from catching
coronavirus wearing a mask might make
people feel
a little bit better and it might even
block a droplet
but it's not providing the perfect
protection that people
think that it is after reversing their
position on face masks
authorities claimed their earlier
message was motivated by a desire to
preserve protective gear for medical
workers
without ever acknowledging that they
were wrong to say that masks wouldn't
slow the spread of the virus
do you now regret not advising people
more forcefully to wear masks
earlier i don't regret that because let
me explain to you
what happened at that time there was a
paucity
of equipment that our health care
providers needed
public health authorities also issued
contradictory messages on the safety of
large
gatherings following the black lives
matter protests the who
failed to properly investigate the
original outbreak in china
perhaps leaving the world less prepared
than it should have been for the
emerging pandemic
the trump administration repeatedly
played down the threat of the virus and
the cdc
botched the early rollout of testing if
there is any hope of winning back public
trust
in a vaccination program which unlike
the 1973 swine flu vaccine
will have been subject to extensive
safety testing public health authorities
should acknowledge their past mistakes
we did not want to divert
masks and ppe away from them
to be used by the people if warning
against face masks was a so-called noble
lie
to preserve supplies for healthcare
workers they should own up to that
rationale
and stop condescending to the public
doctors should acknowledge that vaccines
can carry some risk
but that it's a risk often worth taking
because there are no perfect solutions
only trade-offs the lesson of the last
six months
is that authoritarian mandates and noble
lies
tend to backfire fact-based persuasion
which is the basis of good science
is our best hope for stopping covet 19
and restoring the personal freedom
that's been eroded by the governmental
and societal response to it